Korean John Pierre all she does she has
nothing she can't comment about politics
she can't say anything honestly saki's
gonna Circle back listen to this little
piece of Wizardly wisdom from Corinne
why is why is the American Military
shooting something out of the sky over
Canada because it's part of NORAD there
is the NORAD is part of like a part of
uh it's a it's a what you call a
coalition of course
exactly and so that's why we were able
to do that again we didn't do it on our
own we did it in in
clearly in in in in step with the
Canadia
Canadia we did it with Canadian people
she's an idiot I mean she has no idea
what she's saying she moves her she's
doing this a lot because she's trying to
put words together because what I always
say to her she's just picking words and
she grabs words from thin air and she
puts them into a sentence she could not
tell you what NORAD is he had to kind of
walk her there
and Canadia is always at war with East
Asia you get it all right
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]